about two years ago a pair of friends
went from visiting coffee houses to
having their own coffee sold in stores
nationwide the two are co-founders of
blk and bold specialty beverages
as jody long reports their successes are
much bigger than just coffee beans
there is definitely a balance between
science and art
then call this warehouse on des moines
southwest side
a canvas for a mad scientist we're so
knee deep into this
it's here where black and bold comes
alive roasted
packaged and shipped out across the
country the brainchild of purnell cesar
and his childhood friend rod johnson
black and bowl is a double entendre
so it represents the contents the
products that are in the bag black
coffee
black tea bold flavoring but it also
represents pernell and i
as entrepreneurs as people right
black men who are on a bold journey to
make a real difference
since launching in 2018 the pair have
sold more than 275 thousand bags
and signed on with major retailers like
hyvee
whole foods target even amazon
representation matters
period the duo making their mark we are
the first
nationally nationally distributed coffee
brand in america
but it does make us question why are we
the first
in the coffee industry i've been black
forever right
and so i don't really define my
efforts and my moves as black first but
i do recognize that people on the
outside looking in
see that and coffee lovers are liking
what they see
well taste for that matter the push to
buy black
bringing with it new customers the shift
in the national conversation
has really brought or brought more
people
into our ecosystem and we're hoping that
we do
right now that we have their attention
with something that's
embedded in their daily ritual but not
just for coffee drinkers
the pair's real goal goes much deeper
it was until we stepped back from having
those cups of coffee
talking about other things that we
realized that that
cup would be the vehicle to help connect
people
back to the needs state that we want to
focus on proceeds from sales are given
to at-risk youth programs both here
and around the country us being black
men us being black us coming from
being minorities all of those things
anywhere someone can relate to
what we're doing by way of seeing
themselves is is
hugely important for us the company's
success rooted in the des moines
community
creating a legacy one caffeinated
thought
at a time people
are connected to what we're doing in the
way that we hoped
uh is that they you know didn't just
believe in the product but they also
believed in the purpose
and they also you know in in the inverse
of that because uh the more we can build
a community of people that
think differently by way of their
interaction with us is
you know a seed planted for the future